if you got into ethereum early on in the
crowd sale and you you bet on that thing
at 30 cents because uh you're a
developer and you you really believed in
this new programmable blockchain
you deserve your tens of millions of
dollars you deserve your 100 million
dollars
if you're rich because you bought like a
picture of a rock you know three months
ago or you know a computer generated
squiggle that's now worth a quarter
million dollars [__] you
yeah
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my all in it like my days off on
the road let's travel never looking back
i'm looking at my uh my phone i just got
a text message because my my three
nieces went back to the winter you know
first day of school today
and uh i was talking to one of them this
morning and i go ellie how you know how
are you feeling
first day ever going to a school and she
goes
i go i go how are you feeling in one
word she goes my heart is going fast
i was like oh i'm melted i'm melted your
uncle is a puddle on the ground now he
cannot function anymore so that's
awesome shout out to ellie for uh her
first day of school hopefully it's going
well
that's awesome
that's a great one
okay um can i start by telling you a
quick story that i don't think i've ever
told you but i think you'll get a kick
out of
so
about
this is the bitcoin one we'll tell that
one soon but about three years ago
i so
i talk about solid time so i don't want
to like
rub it or like continue talking about
this [__] because it gets boring but
basically i don't do any drugs i don't
drink i'm pretty straight lace all right
i've been straight laced for eight years
i don't do anything i'm i'm fearful of
anything but
i was getting really curious about uh
uh psychedelics
so like mushrooms okay mdma therapy
ketamine therapy i did what a lot of
people did i read the book how to change
your mind by michael pollan and i was
like oh this is great i'm really
interested in this and so i found a
person who was going to lead a an mdma
therapy like session and so i went to
dinner at her house
with my wife came with me and it was
like
three other couples and we went to this
thing and i was we were and she wanted
to do like a session to get to know
people in order to determine if this was
a good fit because basically what you do
is you take a
dose of mdma and then like she's talking
about molly
i think so
yeah i believe so uh it's all or similar
at least i'm not i i really frankly
don't know but i think it's like the
same thing
and we uh you eat it you drink it it's
like a pig
it's like a pill i guess it's a pill you
swallow it okay and we go to this group
and
i'm into like the the idea of
psychedelics for therapy like uh to like
you know for veterans but also people
who just want breakthroughs or who have
depression i'm on board with i've got
friends to do it i love it i don't
really do i don't do drugs because i
just don't feel comfortable doing it but
i really wanted to explore it and get
and get to know these people and try
this out and i went to this group
and
they were crazy hippy dippy like super
hippy dippy but mind you this is in san
francisco and she had a really nice
place
and so like we start talking
and
all of a sudden it gets so hippy-dippy
and woo-woo that she's like
you know like this medicine needs to be
free for everyone and capitalism is just
ruining everything
and
like you know we need to live in a
society where we can just barter and
trade and like this way we can get some
medicine let me just guess sam triggered
it starts a debate triggered so hard and
uh
and then we start talking we i'm like in
my back of my head i'm like well then
why am i paying you like four thousand
dollars for this
but
you're like yeah refund me right yeah so
give my money back and we start talking
and like this is just sitting in my head
and i'm like oh man four grand this
thing was four grand to do or 2500 it
was like multiple thousands of dollars i
think it was closer to three or four
thousand than it was two thousand i
forget the exact amount because you can
take a family of four to disneyland get
the fast pass get the turkey leg go get
the mickey mouse ears and still come in
under four grand that's a real
psychedelic experience if you want yeah
i look i agree it was crazy but look i'm
trying to be open-minded i wanted to
explore this i i just read the book i
was all enthused but in my head i'm just
sitting there at this dinner with this
in the back of my head and i'm thinking
about this i'm like oh my god like i
can't believe like this is these people
are so [__] and and then i i asked
her and i go what what did you used to
do for a living
she used to work at lehman brothers
and now has a venture capital firm on
the side
and this whole and and i like when i
heard this i was like i started giggling
and i was like well you do realize that
this is like just ridiculous what you
said earlier right and i said this at
the dinner i'm like you know that's
that's just like crazy and they are also
talking about how like this medicine
needs to be available for everyone and
like they need to help the masses and
they're like where are you from i'm like
i'm from missouri and they said oh
flyover country uh and i'm just like oh
my god this is the most smug thing ever
so eventually i get into an argument
with her at the dinner table and she was
just like you know i don't think this is
a good fit and i was like i agree this
is not a good fit i can't do drugs with
you not a good fit
and so i can't even do dinner with you
yeah i can do dinner with you let alone
like get high and talk about my feelings
with you like not going to work this is
a horrible fit and so i just i had to
leave i got kicked out like i basically
got asked to leave
and
they're like sarah you're cool
yeah
i i just wasn't in a good place and so i
got kicked out of the group i wasn't
able to do drugs with them
and that was my experience with
psychedelic uh that was my only
experience with like the psychedelic
therapy but
i think
that these style these retreat styles
for psychedelic stuff
starting in like 2015 i had friends that
would go do ayahuasca you know ayahuasca
is
oh so i've heard ayahuasca many times so
i know of it i know kind of what the
what the the why people do it you should
explain it anyways but if you said hey
this is like my dolly parton thing i
couldn't pick dolly parton out of a
lineup if you said hey draw ayahuasca
i draw some feathers in a in a bowl of
liquid i don't think that what the hell
is actually
i don't think you're far off again i'm a
total noob here as well but my friends
do it i believe it's like a powder and
you mix it with water and you put it in
a bowl or whatever and you like pass
around like this thing and you take a
drink out of it and then you stay up all
night like doing wild stuff and like you
a lot of times they make it makes you
throw up and that's like part of the the
journey and experience it's freaking
weird but like whatever i'm open to it
and i've been had i've had friends like
start doing this in 2015. now on
instagram i am seeing so many of my
friends go to south america go to mexico
all talking about like these journeys i
started listening to this health podcast
backpacking through europe is 100
america
and i and i like to make fun of it
because it's some basic bit [__] but you
want to know what
it's i'm on board i'm so on board with
this i am totally on board with this and
i think that psychedelic retreats like
i've been i read a bloomberg article
about them and uh this guy in jamaica
and they charge like
it ranges from 25 000 to 2500 to 30 000
and they bring you to this like nice
place they get you they give you the the
drugs like it's a variety of sometimes
it's ayahuasca ketamine um
uh what's it still asylum what's
mushrooms um yeah and they like do this
therapy stuff i am so on board with this
and unfortunately my one experience was
horrible but i'm so on board with this
it wasn't the drugs it was the people it
was the people it was the hypocrites
that they're trying to get me to take
this drug
yeah i'm like like i can't trust you
like you're gonna tell me like you want
to solve you want to like like solve the
world's problems and you're gonna make
fun of me for being from missouri like
that this like this is a bad fit uh you
know right just tell me your [__]
first dude i i have so many
yeah exactly it's like a a meeting it's
like hi i'm sam and i'm full of [__]
yeah all right so
so i have a bunch of thoughts about this
uh where do i begin first
shout out to the guy who came to our
live podcast show in austin who is
apparently
his mushroom dealer don't remember his
name i remember that showed me some show
he loved that like i loved to take out
his phone and just show pictures of his
he opened up his camera roll
not a single friend or family there just
different exotic mushrooms in his hand
and they all look the same
they all look so he kept showing like
dirt
i was like yeah cool man cool somebody
who's never never done mushrooms
couldn't couldn't tell it was like
showing me different bottles of wine and
i'm sober like i uh yeah okay it looks
great it looks fantastic that one's that
was dark red cool
so
that's one thing i just remember that
guy when you were telling this story
second
i've i met this guy who's really
interesting
uh did i tell you about this guy robbie
bent
no
okay so
this is this is cool all right so this
guy
so robbie ben what's his story so he's a
founder of a he's a startup founder
he has this idea for
um by the way when i tell stories i'm
pretty sure like at least 40 of them are
just the details are completely wrong
but i always get the essence of the
story right so i'll say that so robby if
i butcher your story sorry about that
all right so i think he had a startup
that was like
this was back when cell phone roaming
was a big problem like you would go
travel somewhere and you're if you like
turned your phone on for one minute
you'd like spent a thousand dollars so
basically roaming was a problem and so
he was trying to build this like sim
card company for like international
roaming like an international sim card
and raises i think like 25 million
dollars or something like that
and uh you know like pretty soon after
that uh like roaming became like free or
something you know something happened
the company like
was pointless at some point and he's
like oh [__] okay
uh what do i do now company kind of
fails he's kind of in a funk he's in a
depression and so i think he was
uh he was i think he was depressed i
think he was using drugs i'm not sure
exactly what the story was but he's kind
of in a low place in life
and his friend is like
you know what you need to go backpacking
through europe you need to go to south
america and do some ayahuasca or he
decides he's going to do it so he goes
on this ayahuasca trip
and he's like uh you know same story as
everybody who goes to burning man or
south america for ayahuasca they're like
oh life-changing best experience i think
if you don't have a good experience they
must just kill you because i've never
met anybody who didn't have a
life-changing experience it's all
positive so so he's got this all
positive experience and he meets this
person there also doing the trip
and um and they're you know i was
hanging out together and this guy's like
hey he's like you know so what do you do
he's like oh you know robbie's like i
just went through this crazy thing i'm
like broke my company failed i'm like in
the dumps and this guy's like oh you
know i'm uh i'm actually creating this
crypto venture capital fund this is five
years ago six years ago now he's like
you know i'm we're raising one of the
first funds for crypto to invest in
crypto
and um you know like a lot of these
people we invest in they're like you
know great engineers or they're uh
they're just really into crypto but
they're not great at marketing and so
like maybe you could just help out some
of my portfolio companies like if you've
got nothing else to do just come hang
out with me and let's let's do this and
by the way you should check out this
thing called ethereum
and uh and so he's like oh ethereum
what's that they just done its crowd
sale i think ethereum was like at six
dollars at the time so ethereum today is
like 3 500 as of this morning
and uh
and so he
he starts organizing all these like
meetups so he's like i don't know
anything about crypto but this guy said
get in there's a lot of energy here and
he followed his gut after the ayahuasca
trip and was like look i got nothing to
lose so let me do this
and he starts organizing like basically
like hackathons and then with the
hackathons he gets engineers and then he
tells the engineers hey you should go
work at these like portfolio companies
potentially so he's like kind of
creating some values just helping a
bunch of people out and he starts
getting really interested in ethereum
because he's like that's where the most
energy is so he starts organizing like
all the ethereum hackathons and people
are loving it the ethereum foundation
reaches out it's like hey
you should come on and be like the first
marketing person for ethereum so this
guy joins joins uh the ethereum project
and he's the first kind of like marketer
guy non-technical person working on the
thing and he's basically building the
community and the passion around it he's
hosting events and things like that
and so
he went from like the dumps he gets into
ethereum like under ten dollars ethereum
runs up and by the way i was like i
asked him i was like did you like
how big did you bet on this he's like
well i had nothing he's like but i took
every dollar i had and i put it into
ethereum he was like i didn't have much
i heard it's probably like 10 grand or
something like that he's like i think i
borrowed money from like my parents and
i just put it all into ethereum and it
was like amazing for me and so anyways
he makes life-changing money and uh and
after a couple years in the crypto scene
he's like you know what
um crypto's great i made a bunch of
money doing this now but i'm ready for
my next thing and he's like goes back to
his roots he's like that psychedelic
trip ayahuasca trip was like so
meaningful for me so he in the meantime
had been getting into all kinds of like
different types of like kind of
therapies so he was like cold therapy
heat therapy breath work all these like
kind of like you know kind of like these
hippy-dippy like sort of alternative
ways to like improve your body and so
when i called him i met him for the
first time he's on the zoom
and his background is like this oasis
i'm like oh cool background like cool
background image he's like no this is
like my garage i built out and he
basically built this in he's in canada
he built this epic like wood cabin
looking thing it's got this custom cold
plunge he made it's this 20 person sauna
that he created because he hosts events
there it's got all this greenery it's
like a greenhouse he's got this like
musical stuff and he created basically
this experience where you could come if
you wanted to have one of these
experiences you could do hot cold
therapy and he would take you through an
intense cold plus heat like you know you
go back and forth between that like a
like a banya bath type situation
and then the second thing he did was
these like kind of facilitated mdma type
i don't know what drug it was but
facilitated like psychedelic experiences
where they have a doctor on site
and then they do this like group
experience together and you're guided
through it exactly like what you're
talking about yeah and i was like dude
that's a great idea i was like because
you know i'm a [__] i don't i kind of
want to have a life-changing experience
but like with no risk can you like give
me that and this is like the closest
you're gonna get which is like doctor
supervised in a group of people with
people who've done this before and like
it's for beginners and it's not just go
do drugs in the in the in this like
sketchy place like in a nice beautiful
environment with music and it's
controlled
he's like yeah dude i put this up like i
think he put it up on airbnb as an
experience or he put it up a groupon or
something i don't know where he put it
we put it somewhere and he's just like
booked out his his little like garage is
basically booked out like 24 7. and
since then he basically uh he's he he's
like his next thing or the way he like
evolved it he's like still he still does
the live events but to scale it up he
created this app called um inward and so
i invested in this thing it's basically
a breath work app so i started doing
this every morning now the app's not
even like fully out yet like you just
sent me doing it
yeah because i'm into i'm into breath
work i like kind of heard about when wim
hof and dabbled with that
and i went to this buddhist thing once
and like they do chanting which is like
a form of like meditation i've done it
before too it's great and so you should
i'm gonna send you the soundcloud link
uh and i had him come in my course when
i taught the writing course i was like
dude this thing's amazing i use this now
for my morning routine like wake me up
basically so i was like you know
teaching over zoom can be the most
[__] boring thing
and so i had him come in and do a five
minute session for the students at the
beginning and everybody was like hyped
out of their mind by the end of it also
some people were like yo i'm like
lightheaded i need to like go sit down
it's like yeah yeah that happens but he
has this five minute guiding thing where
it's like
dope music mixed with a guided breath
work session and he did in five minutes
he was like waking everyone up anyway so
i'm pretty like excited about this and i
thought his story was pretty awesome of
like his little journey to get here so i
wanted to share that with you so
well let's just keep going so i went to
um when i lived in san francisco these
guys i met these young guys on uh they
went to stanford they were
[Laughter]
they weren't that young uh these guys
these guys that went to stanford they
basically i found this thing on
eventbrite where they were doing
like it was very clear what was
happening which was it was two guys
testing a startup idea and they either
got someone to donate them a really big
room uh or they like rented it for a
very little amount of money but i think
someone just donated them this room and
one of them was like an enthusia
enthusiastic person or enthusiast of
breath work and he they basically we all
went there and they put this
eventbrite link up we each paid 30 and
30 of us went there so uh what's 30
times 30 is that
900. okay uh well we yeah we don't do
public math and so yeah
i take that i bleep that out i don't do
public math
uh so i went to his i went to this guy
and he the the lights were down and they
start playing this music and like i went
with my co-worker he was like hey i
found this thing on eventbrite let's go
check it out and we went to his place
and 30 of us did breath like a breath
work session it was it was have you been
to a soul cycle studio
i was gonna say yeah it sounds like
exactly
yeah it felt exactly like that and it
was the best business ever and they were
clearly i talked to him afterwards he's
like yeah we're just testing this out
and we might turn it into a business and
they didn't do it and they totally
should have because it was way better
than soul cycle why they had nothing it
was just a room with lights sound and
you're sitting there and they just hit
play and the guy guides you a little bit
he kind of talks to you and it was
awesome but it was like the
you walk out with a high so you've given
people
an experience so we talked about this a
while ago with the simone biles thing we
made a prediction that
next five years mental fitness not
mental health mental fitness which is
training your body and your brain to
sort of like be able to master your mind
a little bit better um and not just
avoid disease and illness but actually
be fit mentally um this is gonna become
more in vogue i think that this breath
work i think breath work is gonna be the
new meditation um i think that the
same way that you know soul cycle and
barry's boot camp and hot yoga have
become these alternative you know we had
the gym which is this kind of cold
sterile isolated solo one player
experience
and then you have soul cycle come in
it's like no this is multiplayer with a
leader you just submit to they just tell
you they just shout tell you what to do
and they're like they look heroic on the
stage with their body and their voice
and their microphone
and then we're going to program you with
this music that you can't help but feel
like you just went to the club we're
going to heat you up so you sweat
because that feels good you're going to
feel like you've got a workout in and
we're going to guide you through a
process and whether that process is
cycling or it's boxing at rumble or it's
barry's boot camp and you're running on
a treadmill or it's hot yoga and you're
you know trying to touch your toes
this is a model that works it is an
experience that you give somebody is a
feeling it is a one hour guaranteed high
that you get to you get to get without
the use of drugs and so um so i'm pretty
convinced that there's going to be a
breathwork style
version of barry's boot camp or or hot
yoga that becomes just as popular as
some of those other ones perhaps even
more popular and i think that the app
that he's building is going to be like a
calm comm style app if they execute well
because i think there's a big market for
this you know these are sort of like
ancient techniques completely can be
modernized another thing that stood out
for during your story was i i've
actually read about this so i've there's
this like recurring theme of people i
look up to so chris sacca or is it saka
chris saka there's this uh israeli guy
named uh uh vivi have you heard of vivi
v so his uh his full name is uh aviv
nevo so a v iv space n-e-v-o so this guy
he's an israeli guy he's probably in his
60 now 60s now he kind of looks like
sting
he's like this like good looking like
suave looking dude who's like in shape
he's probably in his 60s uh he came from
israel his parents were wealthy they
died when he was young gave him 10
million dollars uh in an inheritance he
used that 10 million dollars to invest
in some stuff ends up becoming the
largest shareholder of time warner and
now is this like big shot guy who hangs
out with like bono and like he's like a
jay-z like they all looked like he's got
like they think
yeah yeah
he's like this like spiritual guy you
could google i mean there's a lot of
like really interesting articles about
him he's kind of like the great gatsby
so anyway there's him there's chris
sacca another person who this story
applies to is this guy named cowboy
cerrone cowboy cerrone donald truoni
he's a famous ufc fighter they all have
locations outside of major cities so
cowboy cerrone has a place in denver
this vb guy has a yeah he's got and this
vv guy has a place right outside la and
then chris sacca had a place in tahoe
three hours outside of san francisco and
their competitive advantage in getting
into interesting deals is they have like
interesting places that aren't
necessarily expensive vivi's got his
place is expensive expensive donald
cerrone's at first probably wasn't that
expensive chris hacker's not that
expensive and he gets these like
founders to come out to his place he's
like hey look i have this cabin out in
the woods you want to come chill and
hang out and he like shows them around
and gives them this amazing experience
and that's how they like end up
investing in different stuff i actually
think that strategy is amazing to have a
place
just to live you can live a little bit
on the outskirts and like everyone comes
to you they're on your terms because
that's the best way to like get [__]
done is everyone on at your house on
your terms where you're the boss they
get to know you i think that's a
competitive advantage i've thought about
doing that in either texas or new york
where i'm staying now is getting a place
that's like two hours outside of the
main area dude let's let's time share it
my my first million ranch i'll go in
i'll invest in it with you we'll get
five other cool people that we like and
then whoever wants to retreat to the
ranch at any given time can
it would totally work like i think it's
a real like a huge competitive advantage
don't you
i well i think it's cool i think it's
definitely cool i don't know if it's a
competitive it's a competitive advantage
in that um
you can go deep so there's this idea of
like do you go wide or do you go deep i
would say most people go wide i go deep
in terms of in terms of your strategy
with people so what what is wide wide
means you have a lot of light
connections loose ties
you know a lot of acquaintances a lot of
a lot of friends but not a lot of
friends that you could call
when you need something or not a lot of
friends who are gonna think of you first
when they see something awesome
and going deep is the exact opposite
it's having a group of you know 10 or
less people that you're like okay i
would go i don't go to war for you and
you would go to war for me and i think
that both of us have more of this deep
strategy than wide where it's like we
have a handful of people that we just
trust implicitly i could give them my
bank account and sleep well at night and
um
and because of that
we can share information we can say dude
so like how how do you do this how much
you make doing this how do i set this up
like what
is this good for me bad for me you know
what do you think or
a deal happens
and uh like this morning i'm in a deal
that's going really well startup deal is
going really well and a buddy texted me
was just like hey
look like get me into that and i was
like okay i will i will put as much
credibility as i can into this to get
you into that deal and uh and vice versa
if they if they had something then then
the same and so i think that the ranch
style escape
is a great tool for going deep so
krasaka talks about
he would uh he had the founder of
instagram early on uh he was like i
think working out of dog patch labs as
his like co-working space and he invited
him up to his tahoe cabin to come like
work out of there and i think he like
stayed there for like a few weeks if i
remember the story correctly like living
in the guest house or whatever and then
travis kalanick when he was starting
uber the story is yeah he came to tahoe
we spent four nights or three to three
days together he was we were in the hot
tub just jamming on what what could
happen it's like immersion by the end of
three days with somebody like you really
trust that person you like that person
it's so different than a meeting than a
zoom call and trying to have eight
back-to-back zoom calls and we had
what's her name uh brie kimmel on the
show and she showed us her calendar and
it was like 30 minute zoom then 30
minute zoom then 40 minute email follow
up then 20 minute zoom then it's like
okay that's one strategy
i want to basically say clear the
calendar you know let's go road tripping
together let's go you know let's spend a
day let's go to this mma fight together
let's have unique experiences that are
longer more in depth and that build more
trust and i'll i'd rather do that with a
few people than try to do it try to know
everybody
same we're the exact same i find it to
be exhausting um you want to do a few
topics here yeah let's do it which one
you want to do you drive
um okay i'll do
[Music]
let's see let's do this um let's do the
i don't know you want to tell the story
about the consultant one i think that's
probably the most interesting one all
right uh so i i i i've not told you
about this guy
i don't think so it's a pretty memorable
story all right so i have this friend
that i was i was talking to recently and
um i'm i'm trying to be a fair bit vague
but i'm gonna try and give as many
details as i possibly can
and basically this person
um
they had a normal job a normal
high-paying job like a lot of people
listening to this they were a consultant
at a large place and they lived very
frugally and they were able to save a
million dollars by the time that they
were in their uh lower to mid thirties
and when this happened this was around
four years ago bitcoin uh was priced
around twenty five hundred dollars three
thousand dollars when this happened and
this person is eccentric they're crazy
um even though like they have their
normal job and you would talk to them
and you think that they're normal
he
likes to bet he just loves gambling like
in a sense of like betting at all like
he it seems like he's that's just like
in his dna he's not afraid i think
you're a little bit like that um
not as extreme but definitely have a
touch of that and so
you know he started talking he goes you
know i don't see any good place to
invest this money right now and i've
been doing crazy amounts of research
i'm gonna go all in on bitcoin and this
was when it was three thousand dollars
twenty five hundred dollars we thought
it was crazy so he cashed out his 401k
he borrowed a little bit of money and he
used kraken or something like kraken to
get massive amounts of leverage like
five or ten times leverage and he
invested all of his money to the point
where he had like four thousand dollars
left of his one million
all of it
into bitcoin
and recently when bitcoin hit its house
by the way this was this was bitcoin
after it had crashed from about twenty
thousand down back down to three
thousand so
it's not like it was just all on the up
and up no and recently when it got to
sixty thousand dollars
his some his one million is it was worth
about like 95 million dollars
and
and and you talked to him you caught up
with him
i i had a a mutual friend was with him
and he and he called me and he goes man
this guy
you like we were talking you know i was
like hey whatever happened to this this
person he goes well you know i caught up
with him he's worth almost about a
hundred million dollars right now and it
totally worked and i was like wait what
he goes yeah he's got a hundred million
dollars at bitcoin right now and started
with a million and did you know him when
he was making the bet like were you
there yeah what the hell are you doing
yeah and i and i went out to dinner with
him uh in 2000 and uh when did the
one three years ago was what uh when did
that was i think i think 2017 or 2018 i
remember which one but there was a uh it
peaked at the 2017 december or something
yeah and then it crashed back down we
went out to dinner and he was telling me
about this and i was like you
you're crazy you're a crazy person this
is a horrible idea just invest in the
index fund you know i'm really
conservative and i'm like just
invest in index funds you're nuts this
is a horrible idea do not do it and he
was enthused so enthused i couldn't talk
him out of it and he was like thinking i
was crazy he was like what are you crazy
this is like it totally makes sense and
i'm like it doesn't this is a horrible
idea do not do this and he did it and so
recently uh when when about four months
ago whenever it was at like 50 60 grand
it was worth close to 100 million
dollars and i was asking about their
lifestyle like not a lot had changed um
and it was just or leaving it letting it
run cashed out a little bit i think like
10 or 20 percent i believe but still
letting it ride so now it's halved or i
guess it's back up again but
and and and the point of the story is
basically
i am so enthusiastic the point of the
story is a dude bet a million dollars
and made a hundred million dollars there
is a plural but that's the point of the
story let's be clear the point is that
like i love that part of the story crazy
people exist
i'm not one of them and i'm happy that
they exist so we just did this episode
remi and i align with the ramit we're
both fairly conservative just like 10 a
year boring [__]
i love that these nuts these nutty
people
are real and exist because that's where
progress come from comes from and i'm
happy that they're real and so that yeah
i just wanted to tell that quick story
because i caught up with them recently
that's an amazing story
uh so i
saw this um i saw this tweet that was
great and basically what it said was
um
great uh to be great at investing just
make bets that everybody agrees with
dot dot dot later
i thought that's so true which is uh
there's a lot like baked into that which
is that ultimately uh was that by shane
parish
he tweeted something like it and then
somebody somebody replied with a simpler
version of it shane had had the original
one i think sahil bloom had the the
the the punchier one-liner version of it
yeah um and i thought there's so much
baked into that which is you have to
remember that if you're going to invest
if everybody agrees it's a great
investment then the price is baked in
right so ultimately if you want to have
any kind of outsized return you have to
be betting on something that not
everybody is agreeing with you
is a uh is a good investment
and so um
and so i think that's important i think
so i think it's important to know and so
when you're doing something that doesn't
mean everybody disagrees with me that's
gonna be a great investment
it's almost the opposite is true if
everybody agrees with me on this then
this probably isn't going to be a great
investment it might be a good or solid
investment it's probably just not going
to be it's almost definitely not going
to be a great great investment so that's
how you kind of use that advice
yeah i saw that i thought that was good
um all right what do you want to do now
uh by the way on this uh because the
world's crazy and we're talking about
like people just making 100 million
dollars on random bets there's this
great blog post that i think everybody
should go read um i don't know how
they'll link to it because it's weird
maybe put in the show notes it's got a
great headline
the everything bubble
and it's written by ftx which is a
crypto uh cryptocurrency exchange we we
talked about the the guy he was our
billy of the week once this guy sam
bakeman freed
um and who had also made a pretty crazy
trade uh to get the bankroll to be able
to do this to build this exchange i
think he's the youngest crypto
uh billionaire or he's the youngest he's
the wealthiest known crypto billionaire
i think he's got a net worth of 10
billion dollars
i think something like that
somehow that's more than vitalik i don't
know how that works but i guess so so
anyways he um
it's just packed with data so it
basically starts with like
bubbles people talk about bubbles and um
and it's like what is a bubble right
bubble is when you get this like sort of
enthusiasm delusion greed and everybody
sort of thinks that everything can only
go up and then you know then there's
just pull back or pop and it talks about
like the size of pops and um and how
when they happen and how that's played
out through different bubble times and
where we might be in this thing then it
talks about like maybe this is a bubble
that will never pop right why would that
be and it basically talks about it goes
through all the data around stimulus
right so it's like 32 trillion dollars
of stimulus has happened globally just
since covet which is the largest
stimulus the world has ever seen
in terms of a perce even in terms of
percentage of global gdp uh you know
global banks are printing 100 834
million dollars per hour
to buy bonds right now and um
and 25 of those bonds are negative
yielding so it's just like he starts to
talk about all these different macro
indicators and there's all these charts
and graphs and numbers and it's very
simple and it basically talks about
where are we at um where are we at with
with stimulus where are we at with
commodities like copper aluminum uh why
you wire used cars up 45 year-over-year
and then it talks about um you know
what's happening in the crypto market
and equity market and i think there's
one great quote which is basically it
talks about like
risk assets so traditionally you'd have
like a risk asset which is let's say
bonds
and um bonds are like the safest thing
and so the quote here i'll just read
this out which is
because of the amount of printing so the
quantitative easing because they call it
qe infinity which is basically the
central bank and the fed just deciding
to print an
unstoppable amount of money with no end
in sight so it says because of this
your savings account turned into your
checking account the bond market turned
into your savings account the equity
market turned into the bond market the
venture market turned into the equity
market and the crypto market became the
new venture market basically like
everything shifted over one unit so
things that were low risk became
everybody seeked higher higher risk and
higher returns because the safe stuff
was this sort of negative yielding and
so everything shifted over one notch and
i thought that was a good kind of
observation so anyways there's a bun
it's very you find a blog post that's
this high density of like signal to
noise i would go read this it's called
the everything bubble and so what's your
what's your opinion of i know that
you're
uh texting with me and a few guys
earlier yeah you you have some strong
opinions what's your opinion of what's
going on with like the the nfts and and
and all the rock like the the
i don't even know yeah i was joking
around i basically said like
look okay if you got into bitcoin early
because you
you understood the difference between
fiat currency and sound money and you're
a technologist you understood
cryptography like props to you you
deserve you deserve your tens of
millions hundreds of millions of dollars
if you got into ethereum early on in the
crowd sale and you you bet on that thing
at 30 cents because you're a developer
and you you really believed in this new
programmable blockchain
you deserve your tens of millions of
dollars you deserve your hundred million
dollars
if you're rich because you bought like a
picture of a rock you know three months
ago or you know a computer generated
squiggle that's now worth a quarter
million dollars [__] you
that was my that was my point of view um
i like my level of respect and like the
level of durability i think that comes
with these different waves um i might
regret this later it might be that all
these people they just truly understood
this intersection of technology
financial markets and art in a way that
i don't get and you know to basically to
get rich with with bitcoin early on you
had to understand like
uh the you know the financial you had a
certain economic understanding of the
world and a technical understanding of
the world and you had to be sort of a
little you know a little libertarian you
had to have those three to bet on it
super early on and for ethereum the same
thing you had to have a certain mix of
technical plus financial like uh
savviness
for this it's basically like art plus
finance uh plus technology if you if
you're gonna get rich during this and i
just feel like i don't know if it's my
twitter feed or if it's everybody's
twitter feed but
um i feel like half the people i know
have lost their mind and um and i know i
sound like that sometimes with crypto so
this is just one of them that i don't
get but
i really don't see the sustainability of
this nft market
i think it is
like
it is built on greater fool theory this
is people that are not buying things
because they like the art they're buying
things because they think they're going
to get rich they think that the next
person is going to come in and buy it i
think there's a whole lot of like either
you know wash trading or painting the
tape which is basically when when two
friends sort of pass something amongst
each other in order to drive up the
price and then they sell it you know and
then you know the next sucker comes in
and buys it you know for because they
think that's the market price and i
think that it could be one person with
multiple accounts it could be you know a
handful of people that are manipulating
these markets
i don't believe in the nft craze in the
same way
that it seems like a lot of people in
tech do i think it's really cool
technology i think there's a lot of cool
stuff that's going to happen
but i think
people are just diving into every
freaking project
and that to me seems
misguided and the the crazy returns that
they're getting like
i'm the hater you know sort of rooting
for it to fail because i don't get it
i'm not participating in it and it just
doesn't seem like it doesn't seem like a
true value creation it just seems like
you know um
delusion i completely agree i'm freaked
out by it
we're on the exact same page it like
that and by the way
as you say when i when i say that like
i will still buy a few nfts because i'm
a i'm a believer of like when i have
this strong of an emotion it's a signal
to me that that's where i need to go
lean in and learn now i don't go crazy
with it i will make small bets i'll talk
to people i will be open-minded because
i've felt this way many times before and
been wrong i felt it and i've been right
but i felt it and i've been wrong and so
all i know is that that means there's
something really interesting going on i
will still play in that field i will
make small bets i will meet a bunch of
smart people and if something changes my
mind i'll go make a big bold bet but i
would say like
the thing that seems off to me is um
you know it just seems like every third
week there's a new crypto project like
yes just yesterday there was this thing
called loot did you see this
well what is that i don't understand it
explain it to me
so here's what i know about it the uh
the founder you know you know this guy
dom hoffman he created vine
and then he created uh some other [__]
since vine
i don't know if he was with h maybe he
was hq yeah maybe maybe he was uh he's
one of the one of the vine founders
early on so he just released a new
project yesterday called loot and so
instead of it being like a uh
you know a crypto punk which is like a
little eight bit character or
uh you know an ape from board 848 yacht
club which is like a you know monkey a
picture of monkey
this is
a black square
with like
i don't know 10 words of white text that
make no sense just gibberish it's just
computer generated gibberish
and that's the whole nft and just
yesterday you could just all you had to
do was pay the gas fee which means just
pay the processing fee to like mint one
so it came out ben saw the tweet ben
minted one
and uh i think today it's worth 10 to
eat which is about thirty thousand
dollars this is in one day
he paid he paid you know probably under
a hundred dollars to mint one of these
just to just the processing fee he paid
50 bucks or whatever
the gas price and then today i think the
floor is like six or six or ten eats
which is like you know no
for this black square that will say like
lions mountain spiking
diagonal line
castle
you know valorant you know it's like
doesn't mean anything right and then and
it's like open ip you can go like you
can build like games on top of it
there's cool stuff you could do on top
of it but like
it's so hard to wrap my head around like
this and it just feels like every third
day there's like a new one and um and
this is where i'm like the old guy on
the lawn shaking my fist like you kids
don't understand the meaning of hard
work and usually i'm the one laughing at
the old guys you're saying that just
saying you don't get it in this case i
don't get it
do we want to keep hating on stuff and
go to whoop
[Music]
uh yeah okay this is the play what would
you call it the player haters ball this
is the player haters ball episode
because i have another one
that i could hate on uh
let's do let's do whoop first yeah so um
well you go ahead go ahead i'll frame it
whoop raise 200 million dollars a series
f whoop which if you don't know is like
a wristband uh like a kind of health
tracker fitness tracker thing you wear i
have one i lost the charger so it's dead
right now um but it's basically like a
little fitbit you wear and it tracks
your sleep attracts your exercise it's
like
i think that the the word on the street
with whoop is basically amazing
marketing
and product is uh it's like
you know not the most accurate but who
gives a [__] and uh basically they
charge you you know some amount for the
band and then there's a monthly
subscription 20 30 bucks a month or
something like that i think the the part
right now the band is free and it's 30
dollars a month
if you subscribe for the year or
something like that you have to
subscribe in order to use it
yeah so that's whoop uh and then same
thing eight sleep which is a bed that
tracks your sleep and it can kind of it
can it's thermo regulating so it can
make you cold hot i had one i returned
it
because i wasn't super impressed by it
um they raised 86 million dollars at a
500 million dollar evaluation so what do
you which
i think i know based on the way you
started it
i but
the reason i put it on here i wanted to
know are you a believer or are you like
you know where do you bet that these end
up how how much do you believe in these
how much was the what valuation
um i don't know i think whoops over a
billion dollars that's my guess i don't
i would have to think i would have to
see that yeah
3.6 3.6 billion dollars
oh and and also the wonderful kiss of
death softbank and then kevin durant and
other athletes are investing you know
that's uh that's called the sucker round
it's not called the series app it's
called the sucker round so the eight
sleep thing i'm well check this out look
up right now what's casper's market cap
right now
so casper between one and three billion
dollars is my guess uh let's see oh my
god way worse 200 million dollars okay
so casper has a market cap right now of
200 million dollars we had the founder
of casper speak at hustlecon awesome guy
great story
really great business when it was just
getting started i made a million dollars
and i think it's first week
they raised prior to going public around
250 million dollars i think as of this
second they have a market cap they went
public of 200 million dollars so they
are worth less than
um
the amount of money that they raised
point five x of revenue
point five x of revenue i think that for
eight sleep i i and i think that that is
a good valuation for casper i'm on board
with that because it's really hard to do
i think that that is what's gonna happen
to eight sleep whoop i think is a little
bit different because it has
subscription revenue um you know i i
i'll buy by the way i think i think
eight sleeps trying to do the same thing
so they don't just sell you the mattress
they sell you the subscription with the
mattress
they're like they won't they think the
bold case is it's peloton it's a piece
of hardware everybody sleeps you sleep
eight hours a night you can optimize
your sleep it has some such good health
impacts for you right like all true
and um you know mattress industry is big
so what we're going to do is we're going
to sell the best
you know connected mattress and then
we're going to charge you a monthly
subscription on top of that
that's my guess i think they might have
no man i think that's a really hard
argument to make
but
that that's expensive that's it that's
another tesla of beds says their their
ad
i um
so when we first when we were getting
the hustle going um this company called
quip advertised with us and i used to
write these advertorials i'm not sure if
i made this up or if i stole it from
somewhere else that's a toothbrush right
yeah and i wrote and i when we were
getting started i used to write these
articles and i wrote this one article
for hint and the headline was like
um
i forget what the headline was but it
was great like and it got like 10
million views 5 million views and they
spent so much money driving traffic to
it and so if you go to outbrain and you
scroll down and you see these little
articles um
you see these little articles on the
bottom of cnn and it says like a
headline you would see the hustle's
article and i wrote that article and it
was called like it was like a hint yeah
it was called like it had the word
sweetie like sweetie this is never going
to work said this one coke executive or
something like that
or what was it
do you see like i'm trying trying to
find it right now and so i wrote an
article like that and it crushed then
quip saw and they're like that's great
write one for us so i wrote one for them
and i called them the tesla of
toothbrushes
and that crushed and they said they
spent a ton of money driving traffic to
them now i'm not going to take credit
for it i actually think i did copy it
from someone but i don't remember now
the tesla of like a bed the tesla is
it's it's it crushes it um what do you
see the article what was it called dude
why didn't you start a d2c brand i feel
like everything every bone in your body
was made to build a brand like this i'll
tell you why so um
all birds filed to go public today i was
reading through their s1
here's why i didn't start a d2c i think
it's fun
i think a d2c brand is like the hardest
thing that one of the hardest things
that you could do in business it is so
challenging i looked at their the
auburn's s1 here's why
commerce kind of sucks the more revenue
you you make the less money you have
it's such a pain in the ass am i wrong
about this
uh yeah you're wrong about this let me
show you something real quick
that's crazy dude you i i think these
d2c companies are are such a pain in the
ass to run can you see this number
aj hang on
come on camera focus on that there it is
that's that's the last 30 days
so your your business has made
sales in the last 30 days
that's right
it's not that hard to build these
businesses it's okay it's a lot of
schlep work there is a lot of shelf work
right like i spent hours yesterday
trying to find a forklift for the
warehouse but the electrical and the
building doesn't support the battery
that we need and i'm like uh where do i
get this forklift from i'm calling
forklift providers turns out by the way
great business to be in just selling
used heavy machinery like forklifts um
and there's a lot of room for like
building aggregator there but uh
but yeah dude if you have the marketing
chops you have
it's like it's like where do you plug in
that if you're a plus at that skill and
i think you are like your writing skills
and your advertorial skills your
marketing skills are so strong
if you had plugged that in on a d2c
brand uh and by the way this is we are
one year and one month into this
business
that's crazy
and that's in a month doing
basically so okay um how much how much
cash you have in the business bank
account
uh a good amount yeah a lot why
because are you buying a [__] ton of
stuff for november
in december uh yeah we have we have a
bunch of inventory yeah we do spend a
lot on inventory but there's uh yes it
took cash uh so i put in
when i started the business
uh i put in a good amount of money
because i put in
so do you have
wow you don't wait and you don't have to
say these numbers but do you ha do you
or you can but do you have more money in
the business bank account than you
started
no uh we so we have a line of credit
basically that we we use so since then
we basically pulled that out use the
line of credit um
but what i'm i guess the point yes it
but
yes we you do have to wait some time to
be able to pull profits out because
while you're scaling
great this month is profitable you're
going to reinvest that into
either marketing or inventory for the
next month so yes you are cash poor for
a while
but you do turn the corner like this
month is it turn the corner type of
month
where oh good like there's actually
leftovers after you
reinvest everything in growth and all
that and so i think that if you have
a good product if you have a really
truly great product
do you think that you have a great
product
we do we have a great product like a
truly great product and so
uh and so when i think when you have
that you're not just like is you're not
just an arbitrage you're not just a drop
shipper just taking some [__] from uh
you know random [__] off of aliexpress
and and sending it to customers and
trying to capture your margin like we
spend a lot of time on product
development things like that uh to get
it right and we also use the product
ourselves so so it's not like so so we
have to live with any issues with the
product so i would say
you um
you can turn the corner and also there's
a bunch of different companies that have
popped up that let you float money so
like let's let's just take a normal d2c
business here's how it can work
you can
uh let's say you rank facebook ads you
put the facebook ads on a credit card
cool your facebook ads should be
returning more than one x
um you know within seven days how much
you have 30 days 30
um
yeah it depends on your product and your
your brand all that stuff but let's say
you're returning 1.4 x or you might be
returning 2.5 x whatever different
brands do a different amount you know if
you're doing 3x you're you're you're
amazing you're laughing if you're doing
one and a half x you know you're all
right you're doing okay um
so let's say you
uh you do that you're paying back your
ad spend in seven days but you don't pay
your credit card for let's say 30 days
so all of your marketing spend you
should be paying it should be paying
itself off you don't need an external
investment to do that okay so now you
have to deal with inventory well for
inventory you have supply you have terms
with your suppliers so you don't have to
pay for it all up front as we get bigger
we get better and better terms with our
suppliers
in addition to that there's all these
companies that have popped up like clear
bank or settle or whatever way flyer
different companies that will basically
say cool for one percent interest
we will front your inventory financing
for you we'll pay all your kind of
accounts uh payable for for you
and so one percent is one percent per
month is not cheap
but that basically replaces the need for
external investment
and so then
by the time you have to pay your bill
for your inventory you've already
received it and sold it
and so if you do those two things
you can manage cash flow well you your
ads pay themselves back before your
credit card bill is due and your
inventory pays itself off before your
inventory bill is due and you just pay a
small vig on insurance so
there's a lot out there now to help you
scale
and i think a business uh these
businesses i think sell for about 1x
revenue
um
which is you know maybe four or five x
times even uh
and do you think that um what do you
think's gonna happen with it do you
think you'll sell it or is this
something that you want to run for and
own is this like a family business that
you want to own forever
yeah i like running it so and i
definitely think we can grow it more so
you know if we could do this in one year
you know
let's give it four more and let's see
where we can take it i do think that
there's like some amazing thing about
these companies which is you probably if
i had a guest
have i i don't know how you quantify
because you have so many projects but
you probably have a skeleton crew
right yeah like this doesn't require
there's no office you know there's
there's some employees the biggest thing
we have now is we brought the where we
you know we do our own warehouse but you
could also not do that you could use a
3pl uh you know pay somebody else
basically to to do your fulfillment for
you
and uh and then you don't have any crew
there so so you don't have that headache
um so so you could do this with a pretty
small team of people there are people
doing this with like
like i think you know um we had we did
an episode with the founder of native
deodorant i think he was the only
employee for like the first i don't
remember what it was maybe five times
yeah and then you know and then and then
he hired a customer service person which
is basically
you know you can hire somebody for six
dollars an hour overseas to answer your
customer service emails and that's your
first hire then you might hire another
one of those people then you might hire
somebody for operations to deal with
like supply chain you know but so so it
depends on kind of like how complicated
your business is but
yeah like you don't need
this is
i would say i think it's probably
whatever you had with the hustle this is
probably one-fourth the manpower you
need for that it is cool i look i think
there's a lot of i was down on it but i
there are a lot of cons i think there's
a lot of pros as well the cons it
depends what month you catch somebody
you catch them in a month where the
facebook algorithm is not treating
people well and they're crying you know
the business doesn't work anymore it's
like it went from great it was a money
printer and now it's a money suck uh and
there's nothing you could do about it
facebook just change something
or there's a pandemic and you can't you
can't order anything yeah
or shipping containers went from three
thousand a container to twenty thousand
dollars a container uh okay now you know
how does that mess up your money and
that everything's stuck at the port
it has i mean all these things have
happened right like all of you we've had
theft we've had uh facebook ad changes
we've had container costs go up we've
had our stuff sitting on a boat at the
port for three weeks and it's just
floating there um you know we've had to
go get line of credit we've had to do a
lot of things in this amount of time
but um so i would say that's what i said
there's a lot of schlep work
it's not clean and easy like doing a
podcast and just having a bunch of
people listen to it and make money like
this is a lot easier a lot more fun but
those can those can get bigger and i
guess i don't even remember how i
started this but basically i was just
saying
dude i can't believe you haven't built
one of these um it's insane to me given
your skill set
so maybe maybe i will one day and we'll
wrap up this in a second but let me ask
you one more question because this is
interesting to me because so you've done
a social app that is like the most poppy
cute thing ever and had
had some had some mild success you've
also have family that are mega
successful in real estate we have
interviewed all types of people you now
have an ecom thing that's like appears
to be a potentially a home run
what would you if go back now to uh
10 years prior
you're you know what you know now what
do you think you would like to do
hmm
that's a hard question that's a really
really hard question
okay i'll i'll rank i'll give them it's
like the oscars i'll give them some
awards okay so
um
most likely to succeed goes to
real estate congratulations come up and
get your prize uh if i had just said
cool i'd like to be worth you know a few
million bucks you know in my 20s by the
time i end my 20s i want to be worth a
few million dollars maybe you know
liquid maybe a couple million on paper i
could have you know 10 to 20 million net
worth uh i could have done that in real
estate um
with pretty much like
no luck required right
most likely to succeed is real estate
because there's no luck required it's
just hard work blocking and tackling
doing the things uh so that's real
estate but i wouldn't go do it myself
like if i could go back now i wouldn't
switch paths to that but i would have
told myself hey look here's here's one
option
um
and uh the award for absolute worst idea
goes to
trying to create the next social media
app
you know
this required
maximum difficulty uh light highest luck
factor trying to catch lightning in a
bottle
and honestly the prize okay it would
have been [__] sweet if we had
invented twitter or youtube yeah i gotta
admit that would be amazing
but
i can be just as happy
not having done it and yeah i can name
all five guys who've done that so like
you know uh that's that's not the path
okay
then if i say all right
um
you know sort of like medium return this
is the mediocre playbook you know the
sort of mild success playbook a pretty
good chance of a pretty good outcome but
kind of a lot of work and uh you know
would i do that
e-commerce is the answer for that one
which is like
e-commerce is one that
i think you can definitely make work if
you just keep trying um
it's kind of a pain in the ass
and
it's never going to be
the most fun or the most successful
right however
however
ecom of of maybe all three of those i
think is the most exciting
the most exciting no way most of you
have been running ads and seeing cash
like that is so exciting okay that that
loop is fun uh that i give you that the
feedback loop is instantaneous and it's
[__] it's monetary it's not real
reviews real estate's not that very like
real estate can be kind of fun but i
wouldn't i wouldn't call it it's not
like an adrenaline like a dopamine
rush right so okay so if i was going to
go back and convince myself of anything
it would have just been to say this
uh look you could you could win in all
these different ways every flavor works
the choose the one with the most fun
journey corny yeah i know this is cliche
but choose the one that's going to be
fun
before the success comes
basically in that case you win win you
have fun while you're doing it because
you have fun you keep doing it because
you keep doing it you get good at it
because you get good at it you
eventually win
and uh look all these things that as
long as they leverage you know either
either like physical real estate or the
internet the scale is big enough you
you'll have enough money you don't need
to worry about money ever again and so i
would have advised myself to say look
there's some pretty interesting [__]
going on in these like new waves like
genomics you know biotechnology uh
cryptocurrency
just go dive in become there's no
experts because the things like a year
old go become an expert meet all the
cool people doing it take a bunch of
invest in [__] and build build in that
space
um you know create a podcast talking
about that stuff like yeah just do all
the things in that space you know
information so you know podcasting so
media you know information like courses
and you know uh crypto you know
investing so i mean you have a pretty a
collection so i i i think the
of all of them i've had the most fun
doing the podcast the media thing and
really it's more of just like
do the thing that doesn't feel like work
to you do the thing that feels like play
to you right so like imagine you already
had the money but you still were going
to work on some projects what would you
work on that my answer was
i would want to basically like i would
want to make content based on stuff i'm
learning stuff i think is cool i think
it'd be really fun to have an audience
i find it like energizing i don't feel i
don't feel like it's work when i have to
do the podcast and prepare for the
podcast
and um and yeah it keeps me kind of like
on my toes because i got to come up with
new stuff to talk about so i got to keep
learning so that's like that was the
most fun path for me so i would have
done that or i would have similarly done
this in a domain like this is a general
podcast i would have done the same thing
but like in crypto like there's these
guys that do this podcast called
bankless have you seen them
no is it awesome it's like
yeah it's cool i mean i don't listen
regularly but like
okay defy is this new thing this is new
wave crypto is this new wave there's so
much to learn about so much to talk
about so these guys they went in they
created a podcast called bankless and
bankless is basically great
great name great name and they just talk
every week they're just like oh here's
the new [__] going on in the world of d5
here's the new thing to talk about
here's the ups the downs the prices
because of that they're building a good
community around them they can make
money off sponsorships they're seeing a
bunch of stuff if they're smart they're
investing a bunch and getting equity in
all those businesses and eventually they
should launch their own branded business
in there maybe it's an exchange or an
etf or something else with that
following and so that's kind of the
playbook i would do given my strengths
and what i've seen but like yeah tried
all i've tried a bunch of these
different things and that's that's what
i think
this is good i think this is um i think
maybe we should end here i think this is
a a a sick episode i was thoroughly and
uh like i was enjoying hearing hearing
the stories hopefully people will enjoy
it what do you think we gotta title this
one this is the play haters ball we will
try next time to hate on less stuff and
we will talk about stuff we like more
but that's all right this is this is the
episode that we hated on everything well
i'll pat ourselves on the back here we
don't default to hate most of the time
like right like we hate on everything
except for ourselves we compliment it
we typically are not haters i i think i
default to optimism so do you on most
everything we want it all to work but uh
yeah i i feel you and i complete i agree
with just about everything you said
all right dope uh okay i'm gonna go eat
a steak and a salad and enjoy myself all
right that's the pod
[Music]
let's travel never looking back